voters in Pennsylvania's 18th
congressional district headed to the
polls tonight for this special election
that pitted Republican Rick Ciccone and
Democrat Connor lamb against each other
president Trump easily defeated Hillary
Clinton there in 2016 so Democrats and
the mainstream media have tried to frame
the contest as a bellwether
for a potential blue wave in the 2018
midterms but is that accurate
right now the election is simply too
close to call and joining us now with
reaction from Miami is former governor
of the great state of Pennsylvania and
Rendell who's probably very happy right
now he's a Democrat and in new york
monica crowley a senior fellow at the
London Center for Policy Research
governor Rendell have to go to you look
if Connor lamb in his early 30s former
military man you know kind of a moderate
Democrat he pulls out a victory what
does it say to you well first of all it
is indicative of what's going on across
the nation we've had this is our 19th
special election and in every one of
them the Democrats have picked up a
substantial percentage of the vote from
wherever they were in 16 so that's a
good sign for the Democrats but
understand the 18th is good Trump
comfort country the president has a 51%
favorable rating according to the
Monmouth poll in the district so it's
solid Trump come with a country lamb
turned out to be a terrific candidate he
did a good job of not letting the
Republicans nationalize the race he is a
moderate he's pro-life he's moderate on
guns he's a very intelligent candidate
he did a good job with the steel workers
in the coal miners got their endorsement
so it's if he wins and it's still close
I have it at 700 votes with 36 precincts
left to be cast well well that's for
sure in Monaca look I would take issue
with this idea that he's pro-life I
think Margery Dan and sells his piece in
National Review this week just put that
that back to rest because he's not
really pro-life he says well personally
he's more than most Democrats come here
you're right that's right governor
Rundell he is not a Nancy Pelosi
Democrat so Monica what does this say to
the Democrat Party
though if this is the type of Democrat
who can win in a district where Trump
won what does that say to the pelosi
schumer wing of the party they're moving
left and Connor lambs seem to move to
the right well that's exactly right
Laura look the the current Democratic
Party is Barack Obama's Democratic Party
it's no longer Bill Clinton's Democratic
Party a party of pragmatists and
centrist it is a far left radical party
Connor Lam broke the mold from that
because he was running in a district
that Donald Trump won by 20 points very
conservative district so this is a young
Marine veteran who as the governor said
had a series of very conservative
positions on guns and and other issues
that he embraced in order to to try to
win this race the lesson going forward
then for the Democratic Party is if you
want to try to get back to an appeal to
the working-class voters that helped put
Donald Trump over the top particularly
Laura in those 10 key swing states like
Pennsylvania Ohio Michigan Wisconsin
then you better change your tune and get
back to the democratic principles of the
party of old which is more pragmatist
centrist
and moderate and reject the Pelosi and
Barack Obama of far-left kind of radical
approach I mean governor Rendell I said
this for some time and others have as
well that that's where the Democrats
sweet spot always was the party of the
little guy and somehow the Democrats
became the party of like the teachers
unions of the trial lawyers of the
Planned Parenthood and I think you they
miss just like the Republicans did in a
different way they missed the heart of
America and the heart of America runs
right through Pennsylvania right through
Pennsylvania no question you're right
the core values of the Democratic Party
going back 50 years our values that most
Americans agree with and we've gotten
away from them we play it as enemy
politics it isn't good
and I tell my progressive friends I said
Conor lamb will cast a very important
vote and the vote that you care it
should to care most about that's for the
next Speaker of the House whether it's
Nancy Pelosi or somebody else if it
Democrat we can bring legislation to the
floor that we can't get to little
Florida that's the most important thing
and if we want to be a party that really
controls we have to understand that and
our progressive wing has to understand
it most of all well you think of the
alarmism over Trump's tariffs for
instance in both
Ciccone and lamb gave you know fairly
decent support for the idea of tariffs
if not as broad-based as Trump's but
then you think of the caterwauling we
heard from both the establishment a
Democrat some of them and their
establishment Republicans more so the
Republicans it just shows you this was
why Trump won in Pennsylvania because
he's for bringing back manufacturing
that both Democrats and Republicans
Obama and Hillary and Republicans had
said we're never going to get those jobs
back and that was an insult to the
voters of Pennsylvania Ohio Wisconsin
Iowa and Beyond and so if I'm a Democrat
watching this tonight I don't care if
you're living in in California or you're
living in Wisconsin or Ohio
Connor lamp if he pulls out this narrow
victory they've got to look at this and
say wait a second we better re-examine
where we are and a whole host of issues
I know the country's different in places
but to me that's a that's that was
Trump's recipe for success and it can be
the Democrats recipe for success yeah
remember Laura that Donald Donald Trump
essentially created a new winning
coalition
sort of like what Obama did in in 2008
Donald Trump turned everything upside
down he essentially was a the first post
ideological president so he takes
positions that are not traditionally
Republican even though he he won as a
Republican president that kind of
cross-current appeal to the
working-class voters voters on all sides
that have felt ignored by the elites in
the Republican establishment the
Democratic establishment they felt for a
long time that their wages were not
increasing they couldn't get decent jobs
they were in the industrial Rust Belt
particularly in the Midwest states like
Pennsylvania and Donald Trump gave them
a voice he spoke to them and you know
what because he's post ideological he
has solutions-oriented
he is not ideologically based he is
Lucian's oriented so if you're a
Democrat and if you if your candidate
pulls us out in this district the lesson
is to reject the far-left approach that
was begun by Obama and perpetuated by
Nancy Pelosi and the other radicals that
are controlling the Democratic Party
their eyes should be open tonight and
they should see even if they lose this
is very close race they should see that
the path to electoral success does not
go through far-left radicalism governor
Rendell got about 15 seconds let's say
Ciccone had run as an establishment
Republican not in favor of tariffs where
do you think this race would have been
tonight again we don't know where it's
going to turn out but don't you think
Connor Lam would have been I had like 10
points at least well at least three or
four no question and look tariffs I
testified about imposing a tariff when I
was governor because China was dumping
steel into the into the u.s. to try to
drive out our steel industry the thing
that Donald Trump did wrong Laura is he
did it to broad-based you should do it
against transgressors people who were
dumping he got a lot of leverage against
the EU and we're gonna see where that
leverage lead